[Music]
hi everyone
i'm rex woodbury one of the view from
the top student leaders
on behalf of the leadership team thank
you for joining us for our first event
of the spring quarter
we've been excited to bring an
outstanding and highly diverse
slate of speakers to stanford this year
to inspire all of us as future leaders
and we have one more quarter of
outstanding speakers to come
and now it's my pleasure to introduce
and welcome professor jennifer ocker to
introduce our first speaker of the term
today on behalf of dean levin i'm
delighted to welcome
bose st john cmo of netflix
bose started her career at spike lee's
advertising agency and since then has
crafted an
unparalleled career in the intersection
of marketing
purpose and culture with senior roles at
pepsi apple uber endeavor
and now netflix she's been a champion of
diversity in business
including launching the recent share the
mic now campaign to amplify the voices
of black women now more personally i
have many common friends with both so
i've been doing a little research
here are a few quotes of what people say
about her
she is a total force she brings people
together
she gets people fired up about the
future
having her in any meeting means that
positive energy will be at least two
times what it would have been without
her
now part of her bringing up this vibe is
her humor
she's generous with her laughter she's
incredibly self-deprecating
but she also doesn't [ __ ] so she um
just as much can inspire and make people
feel excited about the future but she
will also tell you
like it is on a personal note i have
followed you
personally not in a stalker way but just
in a
fan way on social media and the way that
you raise kids the way that you
parent the way that you show up in the
world is absolutely inspirational
uh watching her will make you wonder how
she gets everything done in the same 24
hours we all have
so we are so looking forward to hearing
more about her achievements as a leader
and as a human in today's conversation
with jessica lawson
thank you again for joining us and it's
wonderful to have you
thank you jennifer what an amazing intro
wow bozeman thank you so much for
being here i'm so excited to be speaking
with you today oh thank you jessica
and um i really appreciate that intro
jennifer
that was uh that was actually quite
motivating i was like oh yes brush my
own shoulders off okay
yep i'm out here i love that i totally
echo that sentiment i mean it's so
exciting to have someone who's had such
a
consistently cool cv and who's coined so
many viral hashtags grace
the view from the top stage so i'm just
so excited to talk to you today and
you know social media takeovers are just
the tip of the iceberg in terms of what
you do
you are a marketing and branding
powerhouse and as a former marketer
myself i am so excited to learn from you
today
so let's i'm i'm i'm really just trying
to do
you know some some good work some fun
work every single day you know it's like
that is uh
my mission which is that uh i really
love people
you know i love culture i'm not ashamed
of that and i think that there are so
many ways in which we can
learn from each other but also do it and
have a good time
you know it's like what's the point of
this life if we're not enjoying it
and i think that's actually the beauty
of marketing is that we're able to
bring out the joy in so much of what we
interact with every day and
i just try to find those moments and
connect them together
i think that's really beautiful when you
speak about
what you do as a marketer so confidently
and
i want to start with your sense of self
because you are
so confident i know you've been told
that countless times
um and you started to figure that out at
a really early age because you were born
in connecticut
but your family moved to ghana and then
had to leave ghana because of a coup
and eventually you landed in colorado
springs around the age of 12 where you
kind of stood out right you were
tall and black you were the only ghanian
family up in the area at the time
and you said of that experience i i love
this you said you couldn't be anything
else so you had to become
everything that you were what did that
mean at that time and what does that
mean for you today
and now well i mean it really literally
you know that um i really couldn't be
anything else
i think there's a difference between um
you know when you are just slightly
othered than when you are
fully othered you know when there is
there's no mistaking that
one of these things is not like the
other you know it's like there there's
no mistaking that it's not like
i was a white girl who was a brunette
and i wanted to be blonde to fit in with
all the other girls so guess what
just went in bought some hair dye and
then tried blonde
by the way i did try blonde at one point
it was a disaster
you know but everything everything was
so different you know there was there
was no way
to try and become what everyone else was
and that was not just you know physical
it was not just the
outward you know appearance it was it
was everything it was the way i thought
about the world as a global citizen
you know by the time i was 12 i'd lived
in four countries already i
i had already had classmates who spoke
so many different languages who
had different religions um i understood
the intricacies and the differences and
how people saw the world
at 12 and my classmates
didn't have that they didn't they didn't
have the privilege of that i actually do
think of it as a privilege
you know they had been in one place uh
growing up with the same kids
uh celebrated the same holidays and so
for me there was a difference in
philosophy and approach
you know i had the kind of dad when you
know kids would come over to
you know have dinner on a friday night
you know just like have some pizza he'd
be sitting there
asking if they understood the politics
in uh in portugal
and you're like dad we just can we just
talk about the broncos and he was like
bronco who
for what you know what i mean like that
that's the kind of upbringing i had and
so
that i had no choice there was no choice
in trying to just simply fit in and so
therefore yes i i took
everything that i already had and just
became more of that because there was no
choice
and did you feel that you were
successful in doing that as a child did
you feel
like you ultimately found your footing
or was your childhood kind of this
constant back and forth oh i was a
little weirdo
i mean i'm completely strange and i mean
i can better articulate it these days
these days
and celebrate it um but yeah i was i was
a strange kid you know
i i i do distinctly and listen i'm gonna
say this and it's gonna sound like a lot
of arrogance but it is what it is okay
so you just have to deal with it
which is that i do recall looking in the
mirror and being like but i'm so
dope though like i don't understand why
these other
i don't understand why they don't
understand why i'm so dope like why why
do they get it
you know because i did feel that sense
of pride
you know i think sally struthers and
everybody else at the time who talked
such [ __ ] about africa uh they they owe
me one
you know because i would go to school
and kids would talk about
you know the the picture of the kid on
their fridge
you know the one they were sending a
scent to or two cents to
every month and i would roll my eyes
because while
that is partly the truth right you can't
pretend as if there's not poverty
in africa or anywhere else in the world
um but their entire experience of what
africa was
was on their fridge you know with the
kid with
flies on their eyes and a distended
belly whereas i understood
the culture you know the fashion the
music
the food the uh gosh the language
the beauty of a continent um that
had been stolen from not just from its
people but its entire reputation
you know and so walking into those
situations and
asking or being asked naive questions
uh meant that very early on i i learned
to fight with my tongue
you know i learned what it meant to
stand up
for for myself you know and and learned
how to stand up
for a whole host of people who who
didn't ask me to
you know and so now these days when i'm
in rooms and i'm
one of one or one of few
uh i'm also often asked if it makes me
you know feel resentful um to have to
represent a whole bunch of people
you know it's like if you're the black
person in the room it's like oh let's
see
what does the black person think about
everything black
right you know what no i don't resent it
i've been doing it a long time
you know i've i've been having to bring
the presence uh that deserves respect
and deserves its value
into rooms for a long time so i'm used
to it
and i can figure out in a room how to
change the mood uh so that you
understand
the respect that the subject deserves
right wow that's that's really powerful
and
you know as you said a lot of your
professional career has been about
helping
others also feel seen and you learned a
lot about those skills through your
childhood and
one example of that was during your time
at uber where you
were chief brand officer and led a
project on how to help drivers
uh appear human or feel human meaning
the common experience in a ride share is
that you get in the car
you say hello and then you pull out your
phone and entirely forget there's
another human being in the front seat
with the whole
life and narrative and backstory so uber
you were kind of
tasked with changing that experience i'm
curious as a marketer
how you go about addressing a problem
like that how do you
shine a spotlight on something and get
people to care and be more empathetic
about others
yeah well you know it's interesting
because um
that was not the beginning of the of the
issue right
i found it because of the larger issue
which was just around safety
you know when you think about safety in
an uber or any kind of ride share
the thought at the time was and the
reports of course
so many reports was that it wasn't safe
right it wasn't safe for women
um to be in a ride share late at night
you know it's like there were there were
um a lot of stories being written about
you know the the rides that would end up
in
terrible situations and again not to not
to pretend as if those stories weren't
true or that they didn't happen
but the overwhelming majority of the
time
you know the ride was safe being being
given and performed by
someone who has something even greater
to live for
also you know and so given that
understanding about safety
um the thought then and my insight was
that perhaps we just needed to humanize
the other person
you know who's in the car because you're
not going to get in and automatically
think well
you know am i going to be all right like
am i going to get to where i'm going to
if you understood that the person who's
driving you
is trying to make some extra money to
pay for college
or trying to make some extra money to to
pay for their kids
school or for meals at home or
trying to uh gather enough money to
start a new business
or trying to buy a house or move out of
the neighborhood they're in
like we all have reasons why we do the
work that we do
you know and so if you could see that
humanity perhaps you'd have a different
perspective on not just the driver as a
human being but your experience within
this 20-minute ride that you have and so
that became the mission
and i counted on on some old friends to
help me do that including
spike lee who is a former boss and
now a good friend and i've known him for
20 years
and so i called him and i was like
please please please please please do me
this favor
like please i know you're directing
movies but could you do like
just some five you know short films for
me at uber
uh yeah i i i'm still paying him back
for that
well i think that's really interesting
because as you said at the time uber
itself was dealing with allegations and
internally
it was dealing with its own treatment of
humans and its organization and culture
i mean travis the ceo resigned a week
after you started so you got there and
you were looking at these projects and
you saw
an internal environment that you also
wanted to change for
black people for people of color for
women in particular
but you said that you realize people
couldn't really get out of their own way
can you tell us more about that
experience and what happened there
yeah i mean you know what here's the
thing is that
you know oftentimes like you'll take a
new job for a myriad of reasons you know
um for me i took the job one because i
believed travis
it really did you know i thought he was
sincere
in his need or his desire to change the
culture at uber
you know it becomes such a success in
such a quick amount of time
um that it wasn't hard for me to
understand how that happened
you know it's like i could i could see
how the things went wrong
you know and i believe that he really
had a desire to change it
unfortunately he didn't have the time to
do it and uh that was a that was a
pretty bad week when i when i came and i
was like i'm sorry what now
my boss is gone what okay now what am i
supposed to do you know
um and and also you know at the time
very much as now you know my feeling was
that
there was a moment in which uber was
like the golden child
of everything tech you know everybody
looked at that company and said
wow now there's there's a startup that
becomes the thing that we are all trying
to achieve
and it felt like overnight then it
became like the bane of existence
you know it was just the worst thing
ever delete uber was everywhere and it's
like people didn't even want to mention
the name they would call their uber and
have them stop like
two blocks down so they could so nobody
knew that they were getting
an uber you know it became like this
pariah
um but what was most fascinating to me
was the fact that it was being
sort of beaten down about its treating
of women and people of color
especially inside and at the executive
ranks
and i sat at my desk and i was like i'm
sorry
like have we forgotten that every
company
in corporate america is exactly like
this like how all of a sudden
we just started beating up uber and so i
felt that like well listen if if uber is
going to be the poster child
for having to fix all of the ills you
know around
representation and its treatment of of
women
and uh people of color inside of the
company
uh then yeah i'm gonna sign up for that
because if uber can change
then so can everybody else there's no
excuse for anybody else to continue
behaving the way they're behaving
now unfortunately you know we have a lot
of businesses that
uh say that they want to do something
but they don't don't actually enact
any real change inside you know and uber
was in a place in which it needed to
rectify its business you know as i said
the lead uber was
a catastrophe you know and so anucio was
brought in
and of course he needed to fix the
business and i felt that the things that
we needed to do
to better enable you know the connection
to
consumers um may not have been at the
forefront
you know and again quite honestly as we
already know i think i'm the
best marketer around and i want to be in
a place that
uh really valued my work and so i
decided that perhaps that was not the
right place for me at that time
and i recall in that decision to leave
in another interview you said
you don't need to be the savior you can
save yourself too
yeah can you tell us about the decision
to save yourself because i know
you know as someone who's a member of
underrepresented groups i often
struggle with the balance of you know
wanting to be the man in the
arena and fighting the good fight and
also preserving my
sanity and mental health and well-being
so can you tell us about
saving yourself there yeah the operative
word is yourself
you know this is not about anybody
else's experience like for instance i'm
not the one who's going to say
never go work at uber you should you
know perhaps you'll have a different
experience than i did
i i don't think it's a bad place to be
it just wasn't the right place for me
and i think that's the point that we
have to realize which is that all of us
have
different bandwidths you know at the
time
it wasn't right for me it meant that
like what i wanted to do
in marketing what i wanted to create
wasn't going to happen there
and i just needed to realize that you
know i think some of us like you said
sometimes hang
in you know waiting we're like oh well
six
months from now it's gonna be better you
know all of a sudden i'm gonna be valued
uh said who you know it's like you just
need to see the flags you know and
recognize them for what they are and it
is
painful it's not easy you know i won't
pretend like it is
you know who who doesn't want to feel
valued especially when you think you're
the best at what you do
right you know it's like you take an ego
hit you know and i certainly did
um but i certainly wasn't willing to
sacrifice any more time
you know i think perhaps that's that's
the the lesson that i've learned
um you know in the in the past few years
you know after
quite a a significant personal tragedy i
just realized i didn't want to waste any
more time
you know and so for me um six months
seems like a lifetime
and i don't want to waste any of it
i think that's beautiful and obviously
leaving uber was the right decision for
yourself
and you ended up going to endeavor where
you were cmo
of the pop culture machines that are wme
and img
and miss universe etc um and from one
career move to the next it seems like
you
can't miss and that's undoubtedly due to
your talent and reputation but i also
have to think
you're a pretty good negotiator that's
something that's
something that i struggle with and i
think many women struggle with as well
what negotiating advice do you have for
someone like myself who's entering the
job market in the next few weeks and
really wants to you know
up the ante significantly with this next
move
oh i know that's the that's like the
magic question you know the money money
money
um well i'll tell you a couple of things
which is you know
again it's it's not the same for
everyone right and that's probably
the biggest lesson to be learned in that
um
which is i realize that it's easy to
compare ourselves to other people and
say well i should
make that because that person does and
maybe that's not so true
you know it's like i'm i'm always more
interested at your personal top of
market
than what is the top of market anywhere
you know and that also requires a lot of
self-reflection
and self-awareness you know it's like
what are you actually worth
you know what is your value in this
space um
what are the things that are unique to
you and what are the things that you
need to learn
you know i think there's a mistake we
make when we think
that we have all the tools ready for
whatever job or whatever space
uh and attribute those things to what
then we should how we should be
compensated
you know i think there's a real um lack
of sometimes clarity
in what we are actually bringing and it
happens on both ways right where it's
like you think you're not worth enough
and where do you think you're worth too
much and both of those things can get in
your way
and so for me it's really about
understanding what i'm going to bring to
the job
you know um yes of course you have to
understand the uh
you know what the what the field is and
what is being offered you know
across so you have a good understanding
of the sort of the boundaries right or
the pool and what you're entering
but really understanding what your own
worth is
and being honest about that will help
you to be a much better negotiator
because what will happen is that first
of all you'll you'll have your number
you'll have your the place where you
want to be right and if anyone tries to
offer you less you know that that's not
what you want
yeah and for me it's like you know
there's a difference between getting
into a job with a certain salary or
negotiating a certain
comp um and then feeling as if they they
got the deal
right that's terrible that's a terrible
place to be you know and so as long as
you are getting what you think you
deserve don't worry about what anybody
else is doing
that's that's it i will certainly keep
that in mind during these conversations
so knowing your worth can lead to a lot
of success um
and now your your next swag is global
cmo
of netflix and that's super exciting
i want to talk about the global part of
your title for a second because
netflix operates in over 190 countries
which is
a massive operation um
and as a former marketer i know it can
be daunting for brands to
kind of market across cultures because
you have to find this balance between
reaching the masses and making sure
individuals and specific communities
feel
authentically heard and spoken to and
the reaction there sometimes from a lot
of companies can be just to hold back
from
leading or even participating in certain
conversations
as a cmo how do you push more
risk-averse
organizations to speak up and advocate
hmm it's a very um layered question
there's a line in there yeah yeah that's
a that's a
question um well maybe i'll address the
global component first right
which is that um you know i'm
i'm very sensitive obviously to the
globe because as i
you know start out talking about um
you know i i find myself to be a global
citizen you know and i i think that
there's a lot
of worthiness in other places
on the planet outside of the west you
know that um
the world does not its access is not set
in the u.s
or in europe you know that there are
lots of other places where there are
important conversations important
cultures
uh and that not everyone speaks the same
language literally and figuratively
right um and so i'm very sensitive to
that but it also means that i understand
the matrix you know because
there are ways in which we need to speak
to people or engage them that are
borderless
you know i i really um even today it's
like uh
well actually no i'll give you an
example from was it last week or maybe
the
week before um we announced the a film
called zero uh which is about the black
italian experience
um and i'm so excited about it because
it's like one of the best performing
tweets uh
that we posted on strong black lead now
you could look at strong black lead and
say well that's you know
about the american black experience but
it's not this is about the black
experience
wherever you are right and i think that
just goes to prove the fact that there's
a unifying
experience around the globe on being
black
and sometimes even when you're not uh
familiar with that black experience you
still want to cheer it on you still want
to know about
it and so that community that loves
everything black
is absolutely going to now watch that
film right
um i see the same thing for for in other
spaces
you know where we talk about stranger
things you know it's around a title
and yes there's a certain demographic of
people who love it but guess what they
cross all kinds of borders and they
cross all kind of demos and so you've
got to speak to that entire audience
and then if you have a you know content
that is in finland it probably needs to
be in finnish
you know at some capacity right because
there are a lot of english speakers
there
but can we figure out a way to make sure
that some of the content that is coming
out of finland is actually finished
you know and and we'll speak to that
audience in particular
i don't think it's a lot of hard work i
just think it's a lot of a lot of
intention
which is that we've got to make sure
that you not only have the right people
who are going to be
able to understand culture understand
people but who have a healthy curiosity
for it
you know healthy curiosity because that
is what we all do
you know take your own experience right
with your own group of friends
it's like you would be the [ __ ]
friend if you're sitting here always
concentrating on yourself
right you know you walk into a situation
and you know that it was your
girlfriend's birthday
three weeks ago okay you wish happy
birthday then but you walk in
let's just pretend it's covert time you
got your mask on okay
um and you're like you know how was the
birthday
you know we still celebrating or what we
doing you know that's something
different
than when you walk in and you're just
talking about the new shoes you have on
you know it's it's that kind of
intention setting now while that sounds
like a very silly example it happens in
all of our lives we know people like
that
you know the people in your life who are
so self-centered
and all they want to do is talk about
you know that if they call you they're
not calling to check up on you
it's like a ruse you know i hate those
type of phone calls you know the ones
that they call you and you know they
just call and talk about themselves
i'm like why'd you even call me you just
called your own damn self
yeah you know that's the way i see
brands it's like when when we engage in
the world
and you're only talking about yourself
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
always out that is there's nobody's
friend nobody wants to be involved in
that
but brands who have a healthy dose of
curiosity
and healthy intention to get to know the
people to understand
culture to speak to them in their
language literally and figuratively as i
said
uh are the ones who win and that's the
way i approach marketing everywhere
and at netflix too and
i see intention in your approach to your
personal brand as well i mean you have
an extraordinarily influential personal
brand and one piece of that is your
fantastic style and strong physical
presence and
you know there's real intent there
there's not just like surface level
things because hair and nails and
clothing all these things can be
important psychological expressions
especially for those who
felt othered i'd love for you to tell us
a little more about the choices you've
made about how you present yourself in
the workplace and beyond
yes oh my goodness it so pisses me off
when people are like oh but that's so
superficial for who
who's it superficial for am i do you see
that the crown act just got past
and not everywhere by the way so i can
wear my hair and its natural textures at
work and
not be afraid of being fired for it
like for who who is it superficial for
yes for those who've always had it
that's who
and so yes i do make the choice i'm very
intentional in showing up
very black very femme all the time
because that's who i am and my hope is
that in doing so it actually allows
other people to show up in the way they
are
i'm not saying everybody needs to show
up in multicolored leopard print
i'm not saying that you know or need to
have their nails done or face beat every
time
but it's like however you feel like
showing up i hope you're able to do that
because there's so much freedom in it
you know when you when you haven't
had that kind of freedom it is
it is so difficult to be able to
actually do the good work
i remember the days when i had to
prescribe to a certain way of looking
you know i mean sometimes that's still
on me
you know they're folks who think i
shouldn't show up the way i show up now
you know they're folks who you know were
were in my dms and messages and comments
in august when i got you know when i was
announcing this job
who said oh well don't you think that
the global cmo should
i'm sorry should do what come again one
more time
no i don't think so yeah yeah the global
cmo of netflix looks like this
and twerks when she wants to wears a
bathing suit when she wants to
reads a ton of books when she wants to
listens to
rip dmx when she wants to you know like
that for me
is the freedom to be able to be as i am
so that all of my energy can be put into
my brilliance
that's what i want that's freedom and so
for me
it is extraordinarily important that
even though
sometimes it does take a little bit of
energy to actually show up
the way i actually am right that in the
long run it's
so much better you know those days when
i had to
be careful about my tone you know
because sometimes it would be
off-putting to my colleagues or would
scare people
you know my passion would come off
sounding like anger
i'm like well maybe your idea was just
really stupid and i needed to let you
know
you know what i'm saying like sometimes
that's that's the energy i brought
and i was right you know what i'm saying
no so for me i'm like you know the the
ability to be able to show up
exactly as i am is such a privilege
and so for those who are uncomfortable
with that privilege well listen i'm
sorry
but now it's time for for you to step
aside
because i'm gonna be who i am and that's
what i hope we all are
just be exactly who we are i love that
and
you know on the topic of authenticity
and bringing your full self and being
who you are
your next feat is publishing a book
which is you know taking that a step
further
it's a story of photos of your late
husband peter
who sadly passed away from cancer in
2013. the book is coming out next year
it's called
the urgent life a story of love of
love grief and survival and in your
announcement you said it was the first
time you're really facing the challenge
of
putting everything you're holding onto
the page
um i want to ask today and please share
as much as you feel comfortable
was it a scary decision to open up that
very vulnerable
part of yourself and you know what if
anything
do you hope to gain by doing that
um it's not scary
to open up because it's the right time
you know um i've been asked to write a
book
for a long time you know uh it probably
first started
when peter was sick and i you know i
documented everything on social media
the way i do now you know and
and sometimes i would write long prose
you know about whatever happened that
day
i often posted photos followed by some
you know description of what was
happening uh
and i remember that um a few months into
that
somebody you know suggested that i write
a book of of the experiences
um but as you can imagine i was like oh
no i'm so much more i know
i look like i'm writing something but
it's really just like journaling to me
you know i'm writing down what i'm
feeling and you
you happen to read it because it's
public
but that is not my focus right now and
even after he passed away
and uh you know tried to figure out how
to rebuild my life
and mother my child and do all of the
things
um it felt like okay well maybe there's
space
you know uh to write and there wasn't
there hasn't been you know it never felt
right um and i think that is also part
of the lesson
for us right which is that everything in
its own time
you know it's like your time is your
time not anybody else's time i'm not on
anybody's timetable but my own
you know and so when i felt that i was
ready to write it is when i started
accepting the phone calls
you know and really start to have a real
conversation about it
and i also find that when i'm doing
things in my own time
it seems to flow better you know because
you're not forcing it
i just always feel like if anything
feels like it's forced it's probably not
its time
right you know it's it's not the way of
nature you know that it's like when
when fruit is not ripe it's so much
harder to
peel the skin back you know it's like we
don't need to take our lessons from
nature and things all around us
when it's not your time it's not your
time don't force it
you know and so for me this very moment
in time is it
i'm ready you know to share about my
experiences
and the questions that i get most of the
time or
you know how is it that i've been able
to face such grief
uh at various points in my life and
still thrive
you know it's like how do i put one step
in front of the other how
is it that i'm able to still work how am
i able to
seem like i have joy in my life and
at the very center of it is what i said
you know a few minutes ago about urgency
you know that's why the book is titled
titled as it is because in peter's death
i found the urgency in my own life
you know which meant that i knew that
life is not about the speed at which you
live it
so urgency isn't about fast moving it's
not about
you know can i get this done all today
no it's about the depth
of your life you know it's about the
experiences that you are
having that actually matter you know
that there's not
one wasted moment not one wasted day
it's why i think six months matters
it's why i'm not waiting until
retirement to do the things that i want
to do i'm gonna do them today
you know it is why like when you know
somebody says oh well you know
we'll get to that at some other point no
no no no no no we gonna do it right now
and it all it also is probably the
reason why i've moved around so much in
my career
i'm just i'm totally impatient with
mediocrity
i'm looking for the greatest part of my
life today
you know i'm not going to wait for it
tomorrow and it's a high bar
it really is you know it will challenge
you you know when you start doing it it
will
feel like the impossible but i promise
you
if you keep doing it it will become your
standard and then nothing else will
ever feel the same you won't accept
anything less
because your standard would have been so
raised that everything else feels like
it's such a loss
you know and so for me i hope that what
people take away from
my book is is not that you need to live
life
fast but you need to live it really well
and very deeply
i'm so grateful that you would share
those lessons with us i mean i love
impatient for mediocrity i think i'm
going to tuck that one away but
that's a great one to have that's
beautiful thank you
um i'm going to flip it over to my
classmates who are going to ask
uh two questions and then we'll we'll
come back to rap
so first i believe we have lola thank
you so much for this talk it was already
amazing
um so i'm lola i'm a student here at
both
mba and uh environmental resource uh
students and so my question for you is
how
do you see the wor uh the role of the
entertainment industry
in building new social norms hmm
yeah okay thank you lola um
gosh you know so i'll take it back to
sally struthers because i really i'm i'm
telling you i'm looking for sally
struthers like when i see her walking
around
sometime in the future i have a lot of
questions for her because she was the
face
right of the campaign um around
african children starving and you know
needing the cents
on the dollar every day right um that is
one of the biggest examples that i can
give for how
content changes perception right
um and i believe very firmly that we can
reverse a lot of those
you know one of the big insights that um
we did it at netflix at the end of last
year was just
gathered all the you know all the data
and insights that we could around
uh consuming behavior right and one of
my favorite parts was the fact that
because of the pandemic people consumed
content from other places
at a almost 200 percent increase you
know meaning that if you were in brazil
you were watching content from france or
if you're in the u.s you're watching
content from turkey or if you were in
nigeria you were
watching content from colombia you know
it was like it was all over the place
and korean dramas just poof you know
just everybody's watching
kdrama you know um and i think it's such
a beautiful thing
you know to be able to expand your world
your understanding your knowledge of
places
based on content you know what a
powerful tool
and so i i do believe very firmly that
if we are to do that
more you know if we're able to share
more
uh let people see what others or how
people are living you know the beauty of
culture as we said of
of like the fact that you can watch a
food show and not actually taste the
food but imagine that it's good based on
what the person is saying
and then want to try it i think it's
probably the biggest lesson there is
you know it's like i mean all of the
cooking shows that we have on netflix
i'm constantly amazed by the numbers
because i'm like
these people they can't even smell the
food you know but they're
just watching it you know it's like and
and by the way most people aren't even
trying to cook it
they're just watching they're watching
somebody else cook and eat you know
i think that is incredible and if we're
able to
um fold in experiences from other
cultures
i think it expands our our our insight
you know in the way that we see the
world and so absolutely i think that um
entertainment has a has a very very very
big role
in changing societal norms and that that
crosses so many things you know that's
not
just even about um you know perception
of a country that's
all of our all of our challenges that we
face you know whether they are
gendered or you know lgbtqai
or they are gosh so we have so many
issues lord help us
you know but i do think that if we are
able to use entertainment as a way to
normalize experiences across the board
then we have a much better shot at being
just better human beings
thank you lola thank you
um next we have ori
hi thank you so much for being here i am
a second year mba student
and i think netflix says activations for
show launches have been incredible
um i myself waited in line for four
hours to attend the gilmore girls pop-up
in l.a
[Music]
i know so i always think as i wanted to
ask you
how do you think about experiential
marketing formats for life
after coronavirus oh yes oh ori i cannot
wait for that
i i can't wait you know because the
thing is that
you need various touch points
you know to make marketing come to life
or or to connect people with a brand
right and it doesn't matter what brand
that is it's not even just netflix any
brand
you know that experiential marketing
event marketing
is one of the cornerstones of doing
great marketing
right it's like you've got to be able to
to not just communicate with people
verbally or visually but also use all
their other senses
you know and and it's a great way to get
people deep into an experience and so
a lot of times of course experiential
event marketing is not about reach and
frequency
you know because you really can't get to
that many people
you know it's like you could put up a
billboard and get more people in 20
minutes
than you could out of creating an event
for the gilmore girls you know and
getting people in
cycled in and out of those experiences
but it's so
important right because what i love to
get our evangelists
you know people like you who are going
to go into that event experience that
have a good ass time
and then tell everybody else in the
world like how great it was and even if
they can't attend it
your testimony alone is going to
convince them that this is a good thing
and that's what you want right at the
end of the day it's like the word of
mouth
uh you know testimony is the best
marketing that there is and so if i can
do that
by giving you a great experience close
to the brand
then i've won it is much better than any
billboard or static
image that i could ever provide so i
think it's it's critical to what we do
and i i can't wait to get back to it
thank you
thanks rory thank you both i get so much
pride hearing you talk about marketing
there's so much power and responsibility
in it i love it
yes um i have one last question for you
which we're asking all of our speakers
this year which is
what principles do you rely on during
your toughest moments as a leader
oh gosh that's such a hard one
oh principles oh gosh there's so much
there's so much that i i think about um
but maybe the you know the one that i
the one that i probably rely on most is
integrity
you know the integrity of of intention
you know um because the thing is that
you know you can't be
all things to all people even as a
leader
i think it's one of the biggest lessons
perhaps that we've learned in the last
year
right because i was i would challenge
that prior to this year
um whether it was racially motivated
or um you know gendered or as we said
sexual orientation like regardless of
the of the
issue the societal problem we never want
to say anything
right for fear that you said something
wrong cancer culture is so
thick and deep that we would just not
want to touch it right
the challenge is that by not having an
opinion at
all meant that you actually were
alienating yourself from the consumer
from your audience from your members
from anyone who who is going to interact
with your brand
and what i saw at least beginning
you know um i think especially at
george floyd's murder right at the
height of
blm protests um was a
quick change from companies who had
never said anything at all i mean i i
knew
that you know culture had changed when i
saw a message from
blue cross blue shield and i was like oh
so now they care about black lives
matter too
oh okay okay okay you know it just
seemed like everybody was now having a
more honest conversation
um and one of the one of the reasons why
um and by the way i i said this publicly
hell i said it on msnbc i said on cnn i
said it every every platform
that i i was asked to be on i was like i
need leaders to show up as a human
beings that they are
you know you're not brick and mortar
because like if you're feeling something
i want you to say it
you know and even if you say it wrong it
is better than not saying anything at
all
you know the same way that i would have
like an outpouring of appreciation for a
friend
who's not going through the same thing
that i'm going through but recognizes it
and maybe doesn't say the exact right
thing but i know their intention
that's the way that we as leaders need
to interact with the consumers at large
our audience at large
and so for me it's about integrity and
the integrity of intention
you know that i may not know everybody's
experience i may not have lived
everyone's experience but if i have
integrity
and i am doing it intentionally then i
am probably going in the right direction
and so i have to just stick with that
and make decisions based on that
i think that's a fantastic note to end
on thank you
for being here i know i'm walking away
thinking about how i can live more
intentionally and urgently and
thank you as always for being so
authentic and inspiring and energizing
it's been a great conversation
thank you